Okay.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for that introduction and thank you all for coming on this very hot
Monday afternoon.
The subject of Nazi looting has been in the news a lot lately.
It seems as if every week there's some sort of new Nazi looted object that has
resurfaced.
There's been two feature films made about the subject,
the monuments,
men and woman in gold.
There've been countless documentaries and books about this as well.
It is a complex subject,
so I'm going to attempt to demystify it a little bit by talking about theft and
recovery.
We're going to break the lecture up into three parts.
The first part will be the theft,
Bart.
We'll look at how the Nazis looted art and the vast mechanations that they use
to carry out the looting and the second part of the lecture,
we'll look at recovery.
We'll look at postwar recovery with the allies,
and then we'll look at contemporary recovery.
Then in the final part of the lecture,
we're going to get personal and I'm going to talk about a story of Nazi looted
art that involved my family.
Through this story.
You'll be able to see all the nuances of looted,
art,
theft,
and recovery.
Okay.
Why did the Nazis,
Leah,
to art at all started at the very top with Adolf Hitler?
Hitler wanted to create a monument to his legacy.
He got the idea for doing this.
When he visited Italy on a state visit.
He was always interested in art,
but it wasn't until he saw these amazing museums in Rome and Florence and was in
awe by the artwork that he saw there,
and so he decided to create a monument to his regime.
What he was going to do was build a huge complex of galleries and museums.
This complex would be known as their future.
Our Museum,
Hitler chose to,
how's the museum in his hometown of Linz,
Austria?
Linz was a small industrial town and it doesn't seem like it would be the ideal
place to how's this massive cultural monument.
A more logical place would be Vienna,
but Hitler hated Vienna,
Vienna,
the city that rejected him as an artist.
He was actually a failed artist.
He applied to the Vienna Academy of Fine Arts,
not once but twice,
and he was rejected both times.
So he wanted to diminish the cultural importance of Vienna as a city.
He felt that by putting it in his hometown of Lynn's,
that Lynn's would become the third Reichs capital for the arts and eventually it
would become the cultural capital of Europe.
While Hitler applied for admission to the Vienna Academy,
one of the members of the board felt sorry for him and they told him that he had
some talent and architecture,
so perhaps he should go on to become an architect.
He obviously never did that,
but he did put his architectural training to youth in that he made architectural
drawings of the fear of museum.
Then he got an actual architect to create a scale model,
which is what you're looking at here.
This picture was taken in March of 1945 Hitler committed suicide in April of
1945 so by this time it was all this that the Nazis were going to lose the war,
but Hitler was still obsessed with the idea of creating this fear of museum.
Part of the sub session as well was to filled the museum and fill it with the
greatest treasures of the western world.
He hired someone for the specific purpose of acquiring art to fill the museum.
A man named Hans Pasa.
He had credentials because he was the former director of the Dresden Gallery and
pastas mission was to acquire art from all over Europe to fill the fear of
museum.
Not only that,
but Hitler created a mandate telling all state and party officials that they
needed to assist Dr Partha in his mission.
As a result,
the Nazis looted art from every territory that they occupied.
Now this isn't anything new.
Looting of art through wars,
throughout history,
it's always been to the victor,
the spoils.
Pillaging has gone on for ages,
but what makes this different is that it was highly systematic.
The Nazis actually had looting organizations.
These organizations employed hundreds of people.
There were art experts,
there were people that would come in and take things out of other people's
houses.
There were record keepers.
The Nazis kept very good.
Records believe in are not,
and ironically this is what the allies used and what we use today to help find
looted art.
It's actually very prestigious to be a member of this organization.
There were several high ranking Nazi officials that consider themselves not just
great art collectors,
but art connoisseur sewers as well.
So if you were in a looting organization and you could create a pipeline of art
to the likes of Gurgling or Gerbils,
you would be in good stead with Nazi elite,
the Nazis to have lists of what they wanted.
Even before the war,
they targeted both public and private collections and they aimed high.
They targeted the Louvre in Paris and the Rights Museum in Holland in terms of
private collections.
They targeted families that were known throughout Europe as having amazing
private collections such as the Rothschilds and the Rosenbergs,
but the Nazis didn't stop at art.
They stole just about anything that you could think of.
They still books,
they still musical instruments.
They stole wine.
Here is a picture of bells that the Nazis stole from churches throughout Europe.
Many of these bells have been damaged beyond repair because the Nazis didn't
quite know how to store these.
As you can see,
I don't think it's a very good idea to stack bells one on top of the other.
Whatever the Nazis didn't want,
they sold.
They sold this to fund the war effort.
In fact,
the door Tam auction house in Vienna,
which still exists today,
was a Nazi clearing house.
If you look at all Dora Tam records from this time,
you can see how the Nazis went into somebody's home.
They listed everything in their house.
They started with the most valuable things in the house such as paintings or
sculptures and jewelry,
and they went down the list and included intimate personal items that nobody
would really want to buy such as underwear,
but these were still on the list of sales.
The Nazis ended up amassing hundreds and thousands of works of art and they need
a place to store all of this art.
One of the key places that they chose was in the museum.
Did you deport him and Paris?
Have any of you been to the desert upon?
Okay,
this is what it looked like when it was a Nazi repository.
And if you look through this,
you can almost play spot the famous artist.
We have a degas over here.
We have a laissez here.
There's a Picasso here and on and on.
What was really interesting about this was Reich's Marshall Herrmann Gehring
came to these Uda palm 20 times in the course of the war.
Garing was an obsessive collector,
but he considered himself not just a collector,
a connoisseur as well.
When Hitler would send into his dealers to get things green light to come in and
look at the works of art and touch them and make sure that they were personally
sent to his castle in Bavaria.
And so here we have the head of the lift Rafa we should be spending his time
thinking about the war,
but instead he spending in an ordinate amount of time obsessing about art
as the allies gained favor during the warm,
the Nazis literally went underground to hide art and they had art in salt mines,
believe it or not,
salt mines were ideal for storing art.
First of all,
they were underground so they were protected from bombing.
Second of all,
they were cool underground.
It was cool,
it was dark,
it was dry,
so you didn't have to worry about fluctuations in temperature or humidity and
you didn't have to worry about sunlight destroying the works of art.
There are two salt mines that I want to take a look at.
The first one is in markers Germany.
When the allies came in here,
they found art for more than a dozen Germans date.
Museums.
Here is a picture of general Eisenhower behind him as General Patton and you can
see they're looking through stolen art.
This picture was taken the same day that journal Eisenhower went to a
concentration camp for the first time and he became sick to his stomach.
And it's really interesting about this photograph.
As you can see,
that the effects of war are actually starting to take their toll on this great
general.
The other thing that the allies found in here was
gold.
Literally tons and tons of gold.
So if you see here,
we've got some gold bars and then just bags of gold.
Gold was stolen from banks.
Jewelry was taken and melted down,
but what was most disturbing was the allies found bags of gold teeth from
victims of the Holocaust.
Okay,
we're going to look at another salt mine.
It is an out,
I will say in Austria.
This has an interesting story to it because this salt mine was wigged with
explosives.
The Nazis felt that if they couldn't have the art,
the nobody else should have it.
So they put bombs all over the entrance.
We have some unlikely heroes to this story as well.
Austrian miners who were part of the resistance.
These miners were able to thwart the Nazis the 10th to try to bomb this or
explode this and tell the allies could come and save the works of art.
There were some pretty amazing treasures that they found in this particular salt
mine,
so let's take a little journey,
shall we?
First,
you go down a long tunnel,
a whole mile deep,
and what the allies found amazed them.
They've found workstations for cataloging and even restoring art and you can see
on the wall just all sorts of paintings.
Here is another corridor with paintings.
In fact,
the allies found over 6,500 paintings.
The majority of these were earmarked for the furor museum,
and I do want to look at a couple of paintings at the allies found because
they're pretty famous
right over here.
This is a frowns halls,
but it's this one I want to look at.
That is called the astronomer by Johan Vermeer.
Here it is and it's all it's beautiful.
Glory for mere was a Dutch master.
He only painted 34 works of art.
Every single one of these is a masterpiece.
Every now and again you'll hear about a Vermeer being stolen and it's a really
big deal because it's a huge loss to society and to think that that could have
been destroyed.
It's just astounding.
You can visit this painting.
It is in the Louvre in Paris,
and honestly the slide does not do it justice.
It's really spectacular.
The other famous work of art I want to look at is this,
does anybody know what those panels are from
again to altarpiece?
Again,
to alter piece is this massive alter.
It is 11 by 15 feet.
In fact,
here we see in,
it consists of 12 panels.
It's by another Dutch master named Jan Van Eyck.
If you look at it,
you could see all sorts of Nice detailing and me.
See,
it was this panel,
this panel,
and this panel.
If we go back right there,
many people consider this to be the greatest treasure of the Western world and
it's just shocking to think that this could have been gone forever,
right?
That is a bit about the theft.
Now let's talk about recovery.
In 1943 the allies set up the monuments,
fine arts and archives unit,
also known as the monuments men.
This was set up in an effort to protect monuments from being damaged during the
warm.
So the military recruit.
It all starts,
uh,
art historians and architectural historians to point out monuments of cultural
significance and make sure that these monuments were not destroyed during
bombings.
This was also done to help with the war on propaganda.
The Nazis were painting the allies as barbarians of culture.
They sat that the allies would come in,
the Americans in particular and start bombing monuments that had been around for
hundreds,
possibly thousands of years without a care in the world about their historical
significance.
The monuments.
Men wanted to make sure that this didn't happen,
but this wasn't without controversy.
There were some monuments that were in key strategic location.
So you sometimes see monuments,
men,
bookish,
art historians arguing with five star generals.
But for the most part,
the art historians one out.
And as a result,
we still have all of these famous monuments in Europe today.
The remit of the monuments men was extended when the ward became a ground war
and it became obvious just how massive the scale of Nazi looting was.
So there when that was changed to find and recover looted art.
But there is another agreement that they had and you don't hear much about this
in the history books and it was to make sure that allied soldiers didn't take
anything home with them for souvenirs.
And so on the one hand they're trying to return art that the Nazis looted.
But on the other hand,
they're trying to make sure that the allies don't loot anything.
And that did happen.
The monuments,
men collected vast amounts of data and they were astounded by just how much art
was looted throughout Europe.
This is one of my favorite slides.
This was taken out of Chariton Ellyn Guinn,
Germany.
And here we see a soldier and he's completely overwhelmed by these stacks of
stolen art.
Two stories high.
The allies were finding repositories like this throughout Europe.
In fact,
they found over 1000 repositories.
Okay.
So they created their own central collection point to catalog the works and try
to return them.
The allies agreed that identifiable works of art should be returned to the
countries from which they were taken.
Okay.
Here we have the picture of looted art being returned to Florence.
You can see there's a bit of a celebration going on.
It's just a nice day.
Everybody's really happy,
but this is only half the story.
Once the works of art were returned to these countries,
it would then be up to agencies in the countries to return the works of art to
their rightful owners.
This is where it gets more complicated.
If the works for from a state museum,
that's a lot easier because those could be returned,
but if they were from a private collection,
it becomes very difficult.
First of all,
they might not know who the works belonged to,
but even if they did know who the works belonged to,
the odds of them actually finding that person,
we're very low.
A lot of people had fled the country and in the worst cases,
people had perished in the Holocaust.
As a result.
There are museums all over Europe that are holding onto what are considered
airless works of art in their museums.
Okay.
Let's talk a bit about contemporary restitution.
After the war.
Family is filed,
claims for missing art works and it wasn't just art works.
It was a real estate.
It was jewelry insurance claims were filed.
This happened a lot in the 1940s but started dying down in the 1950s this wasn't
really the priority for families.
The priority was to find surviving family members and get on with their lives.
The issue pretty much died down in the latter half of the 20th century until the
1990s and then all of the sudden there was a resurgence in interest in this
subject.
This had to do with more information becoming available.
There are three factors that contributed to this.
One was the fall of the Iron Curtain,
so all of the sudden all sorts of information from former eastern bloc countries
was opening up to was that 50 or privacy laws and archives were expiring,
so all sorts of archival information was becoming available and three was the
rise of the Internet.
So all of a sudden people were putting information online and you could do
research from your computer instead of having to travel to archives.
Conferences were held throughout the 1990s to talk about what to do with the
outstanding looted art.
This culminated in a conference that took place in Washington DC in 1998 called
appropriately enough the Washington conference on Holocaust era assets.
During this conference,
delegates from 44 nations got together and came up with a set of principles of
how to deal with looted art and again,
they were called appropriately enough the Washington conference principles.
It's a lot of text for one slide,
so I will summarize it for you.
Essentially it says every effort should be made to find and return art to their
prewar owners.
It gets interesting.
Again,
these principles were primarily written by the US State Department and delegates
from Europe weren't too pleased with the fact that America was telling them how
to deal with Europe,
with PE and art.
So in order to make sure that everybody signed these principles,
they were made non binding.
So that means ethically you should do the right thing and return looted art.
But legally you don't have to have followup conference was held in Prague in
2009 where a similar set of principles was ratified by 46 nations called the
Terezin declaration.
But again,
these principles for non binding,
Eh,
fortunately a substantial amount of art has been returned,
but there are still thousands of works that are out there that are missing.
The latest estimate is that there are 350,000 works of art that are still at
large families that are searching for them.
And as I mentioned,
museums throughout Europe have works in their collections that they know were
looted by the Nazis in France,
for instance,
in museums such as the loove,
the Pompidou,
the d'orsay,
uh,
and other state museums are over 2000 works of art hanging on the walls.
This have an official name,
they're called MNRS or museum national recuperation and they're waiting for
families to come in and claim them.
In the meantime,
they are considered airlifts and the states are displaying them.
Okay,
so what do you do if you are a claimant and you want to search for looted art?
Probably the easiest thing to do is contact a claim,
an organization.
There are several good Clayman organizations out there and many of them are
charities as well.
There are also law firms that specialize in restitution of looted art.
This was not a specialty 20 years ago,
but as high value works of art are being returned to families,
there's a lot of money involved in this.
So now there are law firms that specialize in this.
If you don't want to go through a claim,
an organization or a law firm and do your own research.
What I always tell people to do is start by getting a family history.
Know what happened to your family members before the war,
during the war and after the war.
Then get an idea of what objects were taken and if you have any documentation it
helps a great deal.
Documentation could be photographs,
photographs,
especially of the works in situ.
I came across a picture of um,
people looking for a painting and there are these lovely elderly ladies playing
cards with this beautiful painting behind them and that did help.
And how you,
there are also paintings are left to people in wills,
so they're mentioned there if they're famous works of art,
they could be in catalog raisonne A's which lists works of art by a particular
artist or even past insurance claims.
The other thing to do is once you find out an object is stolen,
eluted is register it on a stolen art database.
The biggest stolen art database is called the art loss register.
And if you are a dealer or an auction house that has a good reputation,
you do your due diligence and you check the our loss register before you sell
anything to make sure the works of art are not stolen or looted.
There are lots and lots of databases of Nazi looted art.
Now,
unfortunately,
there isn't a Google for alluded art,
so you can't look at everything in one place.
You do have to know where to look,
but hopefully something like that we'll be imminent and one thing you're
probably thinking is,
okay,
let's say you put something on a stolen our database and there's a match.
Then what happens if it's from a dealer or an auction house and they're
reputable,
then they won't sell it,
but then it becomes really,
really tricky because for the most part,
the person who was putting it up for sale bought the work of art in good faith
and they feel really bad for the family that this was looted from,
but they're thinking,
well,
yes,
this is horrible,
but I paid good money for this and I had no idea it was looted.
Then on the other hand,
you have the family that wants to get back a piece of their heritage.
So you start to talk about some sort of settlement and settlements can be tricky
and they can take a while.
Usually they take several years to try to get both parties to agree on something
that they can both be happy with.
Now it is complex as searching for alluded art,
but it is something that happens as is evidenced by all of these cases that
we've seen in the last 10 to 20 years.
Okay.
Well that brings us to the third part of the lecture where I'm going to talk
about uh,
uh,
restitution case that my family was involved in.
It is a work by an artist named Egon Sheila.
It's called portrait of Wally.
This was a landmark case.
It's changed the way that museums looted art and it's also caused Austria to
create a restitution law.
This was one of the first major cases to put Nazi looting in the headlines.
Prior to that,
a lot of people didn't even know that the Nazis looted art.
Me being one of them.
I had no idea.
And then when I found out that this happened to my family,
I became really interested in this and start at working in the field.
My great,
great aunt was a art dealer in 1930s piano.
Her name was Leah Bondage,
Ira.
She owned her own gallery and she championed modern art and in many respects
it's very forward.
You don't have too many female gallery owners and 1930s Vianna and there aren't
too many that champion modern art.
She a delt and works by clamped by Sheila and by Kokoschka she owned quite a few
works by Egon Sheila,
but by far her favorite was portrait of Wally.
In 1938 in Austria on Sloss occurred and the fate of Jewish families changed
dramatically.
All Jews who were ordered to give up their businesses.
So my aunt had to hand her business over to a Nazi,
a Nazi named Friedrich Belts,
acquired her gallery and he came to her house one day to get her to sign some
paperwork.
He saw a portrait of Wally hanging on her wall and he said,
I want that.
Give it to me and she said,
no,
you can't have it.
It's mine.
It has nothing to do with Mike Gallery.
It's part of my personal collection.
He said,
I don't care.
Give it to me.
They argued for a good half hour and finally her husband said,
just give it to him.
You know what he's capable of.
So we'd Lectans Lee.
She handed Wally over to him and one of the things that he was capable of would
be revoking their exit visa.
So they fled for London.
The next day when my aunt moved to London,
she actually set up her own gallery here in London,
another modern art gallery when she was actually one of the first people
credited for bringing German and Austrian expressionism to the UK.
After the war,
she started searching for Wally and and to found that it was in the Belvedere
museum in Vienna,
the Belvedere was the Austrian state museum.
So my aunt wrote the museum.
She explained the circumstances of loss and she asked for her painting back.
What do you think the museum said?
Ooh,
you can't have this.
This belongs to us.
Sorry.
She wrote letters.
She hired lawyers,
but she had no luck.
In 1953 a young via knees,
ophthalmologist named Rudolph Leopold sought her out in her London gallery.
Leopold was obsessed with Egon Sheila.
He thought that he was the reincarnation of Sheila.
He touched up works by Sheila even though he didn't have any artistic training.
His goal was to amass the largest collection of works by Sheila ever.
He knew my aunt's reputation as a dealer in works by Econ Sheila,
so he asked her to help him find works by Sheila to build his collection.
She said she would,
but in return could he help her get back portrait of Wally.
He said that he would.
She hadn't heard from him for a little while.
Then the next thing he knew,
he ended up owning Wally again.
She wrote letters.
She hired lawyers,
but to no avail.
She died in 1969 having never gotten back her beloved portrait.
The story's not over.
Let's fast forward to 1997 by this time,
Leopold had amassed the largest collection of works by Egon Schiele lie in the
world.
In fact,
he has his own museum in Vienna called the Leopold Museum.
Have any of you been there?
Okay.
In 1997 he agreed to loan several key pieces from his collection to the Museum
of modern art or a Moma in New York.
This was a big deal.
Sheila was becoming a very fashionable artists by then and this was the first
time that some many works would by Sheila would be seeing on that side of the
Atlantic.
So it helped to raise Sheila's reputation as well as the worth of the Leopold
collection.
Several key pieces included portrait of Wally.
There was another piece called dead city.
All sorts of amazing works are going to be seen for the first time our family
decided the best thing to do was to talk to the press about how Leopold acquired
works of art in his collection.
Portrait of Wally was not the only looted work of art in his collection,
and Leah pulled used less than upstanding methods to acquire a lot of works.
So we spoke to a reporter from the New York Times and she ended up writing this
big article about how Leopold used dastardly methods to acquire works of art.
They interviewed my family.
They focused on two paintings,
portrait of Wally and dead city.
When the article came out,
it caused a sensation.
Citizens of New York,
Jewish citizens in particular were aghast that Momo would harbor Nazi lute.
So we took this opportunity to contact the chair of the Museum of modern art to
see if he could keep Wally in America before it went on to its next stop in the
exhibition,
which was Barcelona.
We knew that if it left America and we couldn't prove the ownership in America,
we would never get it back.
The chairman for the Museum of Modern Art at the time as a man named Ronald
Lauder,
you might not have heard of him,
but you'll have heard of his mother,
Estee Lauder.
Ronald Lauder has a lot of ties to Austria.
He was the Austrian ambassador in the 1980s he was also,
or is also an avid collector of Austrian expressionists arts such as Clinton,
Tula in fuck.
The rumor is that he used his bar Mitzvah money to buy in Egon Schiele a
painting.
Not only that,
but he chairs a recovery company that helps Jewish families get back works of
lose at art.
So we thought he would be sympathetic to our plate,
but guess what?
He wouldn't help us.
He was indebted to the museum community and making sure that this work went to
its next stop on the exhibit.
While this was going on,
museums were taking notice of this.
In fact,
all sorts of museums wrote a joint letter saying that Moma had to move this
painting to its next stop in the exhibition.
This is because museums,
we're realizing that if this works stayed in America and there was an
investigation into the provenance or ownership history of the work of art,
if they loaned works abroad,
other families could claim for looted artists.
Well,
I'm gonna let you in on a little secret.
Museums do not like to give back works of art from their collections.
My feeling is if these museums consider themselves paragons of culture,
they wouldn't want stolen or looted art in their collections in the first place,
but that was not the way that these museums fell to at the time.
We spoke to lawyers,
we spoke to government organizations and about keeping the work in the country
and they were all trying to help us,
but things were looking bleak.
In fact,
while he was getting packed up and it was getting ready to be shipped off,
but at the 11th hour,
the Manhattan district attorney swooped in and subpoena the painting under the u
s stolen property act.
As you could well imagine,
officials at Moma were livid.
Visuals at the Leopold Museum were livid.
Eight lawsuit in sued.
Now during this lawsuit,
a couple of interesting things happen.
Museums began looking through artworks in their collections and looking for gaps
and again,
the provenance or ownership history from the years,
1933 to 1945 and they would place these works online so that people could begin
researching them.
The other thing that happened was that Australia was getting a bit of a bad
reputation for having looted art and the culture minister in her,
um,
knowledge and why snus decided that this was just really not a good way for
Australia to be perceived and wanted to make a big gesture.
So they ended up writing a law saying that works of art that were looted by the
Nazis that were in Austrian museums would be returned.
Unfortunately,
Wally was exempt from that because the Leopold Museum was not fully a state
museum.
So this lawsuit went on for 12 long years.
Finally,
in June of 2010 we came up with the settlement.
The Leopold Museum ended up paying our family $19 million for the painting,
which was the market price at the time.
And they would get to display it again in the Leopold museum,
but there would be a plaque next to it,
uh,
stating the ownership history and my aunts all rolling it.
Just a couple of other pictures.
This is Egon.
Sheila's China self portrait with Chinese red lanterns.
And this was,
uh,
when he painted as a companion piece to portrait of Wally.
Those two are now hanging together in the Leopold Museum.
And this is a painting of my aunt,
uh,
by a Hungarian artist named Felix Horton.
And talking to family members.
The general consensus is if she'd known all the fuss made over her little
painting,
she would have laughed and laughed.
All right,
well that is the lecture.
Hopefully I've helped to demystify this a little bit and I'm happy to answer any
questions.
Thank you.
Um,
I'm just wondering if this has immediately what comes to mind is art that's been
sort of alluded through the centuries through war,
basically everything in the Louvre and the British Museum.
Yeah.
Um,
so I'm just wondering if this,
I mean,
I understand this is more recent.
It's probably,
you know,
um,
a different set of circumstances to a degree,
but I would imagine this is something also impacting norms for that,
those works of art.
So just wondering if you can talk about that.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well in the UK for example,
um,
it is the illegal to d session works of art from museums.
So that means you can't give them back unless there's an act of parliament,
which is why the elegant marbles have not been given back.
There has been an exception for Holocaust looted art and what you can give it
back.
They put a sunset clause in it which is going to be ending very soon.
You might've even seen that in the news.
Somebodies government official said that there were not going to put a sunset
clause in it.
There won't be a statute of limitations,
but somebody is trying to block that.
And this seems to be the case with a lot of museums throughout Europe.
Are there any
rules on um,
time and so I'll try to claim any artwork back on their,
um,
what they wish to do with the all going forward,
if that,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
Um,
my feeling is once they get the art back,
they could do whatever they want.
Sometimes it's part of the settlement and a lot of people think,
well,
you fight tell long and so hard to give back or get back these works of art.
Why are you then turning around and selling them?
There are a couple of reasons for that.
One is because oftentimes it's just one work of art and there are a lot of
errors.
You can't divide up the work of art,
but you can divide up money too.
Is that,
um,
if it is a work of art worth a lot of money,
a lot of families can't even afford the insurance on the yard.
But my feeling is once they get it back,
they can do whatever they want with it.
Does that,
does that even mean,
does that even mean if,
um,
if they want to keep it in their private collection and that there aren't any
rules on that?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
They could do whatever they want with it.
They could keep it in their private collection.
They could give it away.
They could hide it in a vault somewhere.
It's theirs.
Awesome.
Preston?
Um,
the differences between Ah,
it was liters by individuals and that was sort of in the more sort of state
sponsored looting.
In terms of recovery.
Are there big differences in the way you see people trying to provide evidence?
It must be much more difficult when it was a person who just saw something like
that and took it off the wall.
Um,
and it didn't go into the sort of Nazi administration system.
Yeah.
I'll oftentimes it is a lot easier when it is something that's gone through the
state system then when it's a person.
Okay.
And the rules and laws for different,
for the countries are different.
So somebody might be living in one country and find a work of art that's another
country and you're dealing with different laws in each country.
So that's where it gets very tricky and very complicated and it's like that with
individuals versus the states as well.
Okay.
Hi,
thanks.
That was,
that was really,
really interesting.
Um,
it sounds like there was an opportunity at,
you know,
back in the past from yours,
from your slides at with the international community could come,
could have come together and made binding rules and didn't do so.
And then you gave a couple of examples how individual countries created rather
restricting rules on actually preventing,
maybe there's haven't even within the Austrian example where there was a
loophole in there that the printed,
um,
are there any plans to create sort of more international binding rules and if
not,
do you have any hope that the,
that there will be
funny you should ask that.
I was at a conference in September here in London and there were government
officials from,
Gosh,
I dunno,
Austria,
Germany,
the Netherlands,
the UK.
Somebody brought up the question of are we going to make the Washington
conference principles binding?
They couldn't say no fast enough and there are actually legitimate reasons for
that.
Uh,
it's good to have this as a framework,
but then each country has its own laws and they want to work within their own
laws.
Uh,
but in terms of making some sort of binding legislation,
I don't hold out much hope for that.
Okay.
Hi there.
Uh,
when was the last time a large,
I guess shit man or,
or a mountain of our work has been found in caves because you read a lot in the
news that people think they found the amber room and they're in the mind
somewhere in Germany.
But has there been recently in the past five years,
are people still finding salt mines worth of artwork?
And do you have any hope that they're still out there?
You hear about Nazi trains,
but for the most part,
those end up being false.
The last big,
big,
big stock of looted art that was discovered was in 2012 I believe with the girl
at collection.
Have you heard about that?
Um,
Cornelia Scarlett was the son of a notorious Nazi dealer.
German customs officials were wondering why he had so much money when they saw
him on a train.
They went to his flat and Munich and they found over 1200 works of art in his
flat in Munich.
That was probably the last massive hall that was found.
What sort of conditions are those?
There is pretty good condition.
In fact,
they are on exhibit right now.
There's two exhibits going on.
Uh,
there's one in burn because for some convoluted reason gorilla passed away and
he left all these works to the Clinton Museum Bern.
So Berns doing an exhibition now.
Um,
and there's also one that I believe just closed in Bonn,
Germany,
but it's going to reopen in Berlin in September if he wanted to visit them.
The hope is that families will come forward and claim these works of art.
So we'll see.
Some are very valuable,
some aren't that valuable.
Um,
but it did cause a huge stir when this came up and they're also restitution
researchers in Germany or who are going through the provenance of all of these
objects trying to determine whether or not they're alluded because Garlits said
that none of these were alluded and they were all acquired legitimately and
there have been a few claims made on them and people have gotten 10 back works
of art from there.
I was just wondering if there's like maybe a positive or a negative correlation
between the type of artists versus like a gallery looking to recover a certain
type of artist does not have a positive effect or negative effect would you say?
It seems like there's some artists that uh,
tend to be looted more than others and most of them would be modern artists such
as clamped and Sheila,
and it depends on who you're talking to as to whether or not it's a positive or
negative effect.
And how many of you have seen the movie the woman in Gold with the KLIMT
painting that was restituted to the era of Adela block power?
That was a really positive effect for the family and for the lawyer that worked
with her.
But it had a really negative effect on the Belvedere,
which had to give all these works back.
So I think it really depends on who you're talking to.
What was the works that Hitler was collecting?
Where is it they the same ones that he was sort of condemning his degenerate?
No.
Oh No.
The works that Hitler were condemning his degenerate.
We're either going to be destroyed,
but fortunately the Nazis Really,
oh,
hey,
we can sell these works of art.
The types of work that Hitler and by Association the Nazis liked were
renaissance works,
works that were ancient Greek or ancient Roman.
Um,
you could show nudity,
but it would have to be nudity without sensuality.
So they were much more provincial type of works.
So was was Sheila one of the degenerative?
No,
Sheila would have been a degenerate oh,
big time.
She climp Kokoszka,
Picasso,
Chagall,
they were all considered degenerate artists.
And I could give a whole other lecture on that.
So Hitler was condemning.
All of those is degenerates and yet all of his sort of,
okay.
High ranking sort of officials where we're collecting them on the side
somewhere.
It's always more complicated than that.
Some were collecting a modern arts.
I'm somewhere big fans of modern art.
But when the decrease went down that this type of modern art was labeled
degenerate,
the Nazis couldn't openly collect that.
Interesting.
Thank you.
I think with that,
we'll close.
Thank you so much,
your honor.
That was fascinating
right.